[Musique]
petit matin deux semaines on prend le
thé au ritz carlton avec nul autre que
ricardo pour parler de rouge et de
velours ont séduit si on part du red
velvet faut absolument oui car on
pouvait pas faire ça sans vous moi j'ai
découvert ce gâteau la aux états unis en
vacances
et puis je tombe en amont au second tour
tout en contrastes si le rouge et le
blanc qui donne à ce gâteau son allure
spectaculaire
samira de chimie alimentaire parce que
c'est le mélange de l'acidité la sorte
de chocolat la quantité de colorants qui
crie cette saveur absolument unique là
ça y est de règle ceux des états unis ou
de new yok mots et en taxi typiquement
milquet
new york c'est le waldorf astoria au
grand hôtel qui est dit
savic et nous d'où ça vient exactement
ce pas sûr à 100% mais le sud des états
unis est vraiment très amoureux de leur
red velvet alors moi j'aime juste idée
le dira ça vient du sud des états unis
au québec ce qui avait fait connaître un
peu ce gâteau la dans le milieu surtout
anglophone je dirais c'est les véhicules
des magasins itunes où il servait chez
eux qu'ils vendaient leurs réserves et
puis messi un gâteau dans le fond c'est
juste un gâteau au chocolat mais son
gâteau au chocolat unique
je pense que le mélange du cacao avec le
colorant et souvent un élément acide qui
des fois et dans le gâteau dans pattes
le ton se barber ou sur le gâteau le
glaçage fait avec du fromage à la crème
ça donne quelque chose d'unique le red
velvet se prépare comme la plupart des
gâteaux d'un côté les ingrédients secs
et de l'autre les liquides
j'ai besoin de farine qu'on va mélanger
son envol ici le cacao puisse y genre le
mélange de standards poudre à part
cabanas de ce pied et le cem et va tout
alors aussi du baba ce qui va apporter
les faits moi le hoggar tôt puis le côté
particulier je dirais pas aigre mais
quand on mange on va sentir une certaine
acidité
c'est avec le chef pâtissier
la belle plante que ricardo a créé la
recette de ce gâteau offert dans ces
cafés et occasionnellement en épicerie
entre les années vingt années 40
tout était rationnée 1 le beurre le
sucre alors il fallait inventer un
gâteau au chocolat qui était possible
pour une famille qui avait moins de
moyens alors on a diminué le gras on a
diminué
des fois le sucre mais aussi surtout le
chocolat alors comment on peut avoir un
gâteau qui avait une intensité puis un
look de gâteaux chocolats la betterave
is no la rescousse
donc la betterave entière en purée ou en
jus pour le coloris donnait de
l'intensité à ce gars tous là j'ai
l'impression d'avoir quatre heures de
regarder ma marque easy cash têtes se
touchent dans la marre d'en manger ça me
rappelle avec le board seront de la fête
a été un peu plus élevée on peut parler
kopecky seeland et moi la masen coupé
depuis le temps qu'ils pensent trop mais
cela ne l'a même pas et pour la couleur
vous avez le choix
colorants alimentaires ou betteraves le
coloré d'arrivée après l'habitera oui il
ya même une entreprise qui en a profité
dans fait color alimentaire est arrivé
donc la vie était plus simple on n'était
plus chez qu'on pouvait l'acheter
donc on rentrait dans cette phase
industrielle où je peux acheter un cacao
en poudre qui révolutionnèrent je peux
le faire avec du colorant
c'est une compagnie américaine qui a
commercialisé dans les années 30 le
colorant rouge en y associant une
recette de gâteau
les américains ont même imaginé
plusieurs produits dérivés de cette
recette mythique le glaçage aussi équipé
d'un brevet lgv est oui la sage en fait
c'est un laçage fromage à la crème
un peu comme le gâteau aux carottes et
si nous on l'adapté en fait parce que
d'elle tout le glaçage trois mages à la
crème puis avec l'ajout d'une meringue
meringue sus etc c'est un peu beaucoup
secret c'est quand même est assez
costaud fac c'est une chance si tout
cela s'est fait à base de fromage à la
crème
ce jus de citron je suis pas dans les
familles américaines mais c'est rare que
tu vas dans un restaurant où il ya
plusieurs dessins puis cueillons pas un
red velvet sur la carte
c'est un peu comme la tarte aux pacanes
la tarte au citron là qu'il aille pas y
céder classiques américains que tu
découvres souvent en vacances puisque on
s'approprie si moi je le faire la maison
c'est réaliste c'est réaliste
cd
les ingrédients qu'on retrouve en effet
la part on était déjà dans le
garde-manger que peut-être le babeurre
le babeurre qui est inquiétant qu'on
veut plus ou moins utilisés pour la
piscine heureuse de manger du red velvet
avec ricardo potable
[Musique]